Oh, pigs are the weirdest one because
pigs, like my friend Whitney Cummings,
she adopted a pig. That what?
What did she get that pig?
I think it was from the fire, right? Yeah.
And she actually wound up driving it to
Texas. She drove in her car 24 hours.
She's a fucking maniac
when it comes to animals.
I think her and her fiance drove to Texas
with this fucking pig to drop it off
at this pig shelter and damn dude,
when you, she's with that pig.
That thing is like a dog.
Might as well be my dog.
Like hanging out
intelligent animal. Yeah. But
when they get loose and they're out in
the wild boy, they fucking breathe three,
four times a year.
They'll have big piles of piglets
and those piglets will destroy,
they eat everything in sight there.
Omnivorous devastate. You guys see,
so for everything, they're devastating
to plants and ground nesting birds,
animals, everything. They eat everything
in front of them. They're pigs.
Yeah. And I hide them. No, I
kind of hide them. I'll pigs.
I think they're an unreasonable,
but the bigger picture is
I need to be controlled.
They can't go out there and just ruin
the, you know, how ecosystem like that.
Well, there's, you're seeing in Texas,
Texas is probably in the United States
is the biggest example of what happens
when,
or the best example of what happens in
these feral hogs are just completely out
of control. They just devastate
these agricultural farms.
They have these farms and
they're just getting destroyed.
Yeah.
I mean,
and I told the wog life of a wildlife as
well because I eat frogs and I'll lean
Lee's it now. Anything that's
on the ground that's edible
though. Eight. Uh, yeah.
Um, I wrote an article
years ago, it was cold,
a killer at the pass.
It was a place in Australia and the,
the property owners like the
ranch has called me up and I said,
you need to come out and
shoot some of the foxes.
Like they're devastating
our lambs. And, uh,
I end up going out there and when I was
driving in with the forward drive at
night,
if the high beams on,
I seen this massive big black and white
ball walking between the flock of sheep
with a lamb in its mouth.
There was this pig and it had got a taste
for meat and it happens all the time.
Like so a big bore,
especially in mature animal will get a
taste for meat in harsh conditions and
they'll just stick to meet after that.
And uh,
I ended up catching up with these pig
the next morning and shot it with the bow
and it actually attacked me.
The first shot wasn't perfect and it
charged me and I ended up like stabbing it
to death.
I was on a slope like this on the mountain
and it was really a battle like that.
He ended up hooking the bow out of
my hand because when he charged me,
I put an Arrow on and shot and just went
down one side and like hit one lung and
it just in fear I did this
ball and he was on me. And, um,
when I was fending them
off with the bow is tasked,
went into the bottom limb or the bow or
the cam or something like that and rip
the boat and my hand and I ended up
getting me knife off me and I end up like
stabbing his pig was like trying to
run me over. Oh Shit. How big was it?
It was a big boy is like big meeting.
It made eight and ball like this and
like how many pounds? Oh, I fucking big.
That's how many pounds.
Probably not 300 down mountain
boys just get real solid. Yeah,
probably 200 or something
like that. And uh, anyway,
I ended up stabbing this thing to death
and when I end up cutting it open,
it's whole insides. Like
it's whole stomach was like
lambs hawks, like the feet,
the bottom of the feet where they can't
swallow and skulls and just like little
bits of a woolen stuff like that.
He'd just been going around and just
picking these lambs off and killing them.
Yeah. And it's a really known
occurrence in Australia. And how that,
if things get harsh, I would just
go, they'll just, cause they,
they just absolutely ruthless.
I would just walk right between the sheep
and just fucking grab a lamb walk off
of it.
It up and Nigga buy anyway.
First thing that morning that I found
was a pig spew and it was like this
fucking spew like this and it was the
same as lamb's hawks speaks vomit.
Oh you don't say Spew America?
Yeah.
Do. But I wasn't a thought. It
meant something else to you.
Yeah. Fucking spewing mate.
Yeah, spew, spew it out.
That's what happened at Disney yesterday.
Fucking Walt Disney spewed all over me.
So they just threw up bones just for our
bones and stuff that it couldn't digest
but end up lamb killer at the past
[inaudible] of animal.
And there's so ruthlessly efficient
in terms of like how much food.
Yeah. So a deal walk along
and it will pick, you know,
it would just pick the top soft grass
and the grass regrows you know, a pig.
We'll go through and eat that grass and
it will turn it over and eat the roots
and everything goes well.
Core just causes a lot of erosion and
then there's no regrowth cause there's no
roots in the ground that greedy
pigs, they greedy pigs. Yeah.
About 'em you don't hit the number one
cause of death on farms. Really? Yeah.
Apparently with a domestic animals,
people falling into pig pens and
just into them they just devour.
And you know when you're dealing with
these giant domestic pigs they get fucking
huge, massive yeah. Hundreds of pounds.
Yeah. In like Western New South
Wales when times get tough,
which is like seems to be
fucking all the time now. But um,
they'll get so desperate
like you'll shoot a pig,
you're going for it for the farmer
and you just shoot it to me.
Not even really taken any made
often because they like they can,
they are eat meat,
their self and their like skin and bones
and disgusting as more of like a coal
mission and you'll come
back in the afternoon.
That pig will be completely skin and
bones cause the other pigs just get in
there and just, and you'll hear him,
you'll just hear him just screaming.
It's the most God awful sound there is.
Cannibalize that. Cannibalize. Yeah.
I was in to hone ranch and we were
walking by this really high grass.
The grass is like five foot high and you,
we were only like maybe 10 yards away
from these pigs fighting and I said to
Rinella, I said, no, come on man. If
you didn't know that those were pigs,
if I told you there was demons
in that case, you would,
you would completely believe it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That was great.
But it sounded like Lord of the rings.
So like some horrific scene.
No monster movie. Yeah. It sounded
like an aura. It really did.
I mean they're there.
It's just how was that the same animal
as those cute little things that Whitney
Cummings is totally cause the
one that she had was like, oh,
fluffy and sit in her bed Q, loving it
that she taught her how to go outside. Go.
Was it a cake wean pig? No, it was a pig.
I, that was the other thing she told me.
Apparently those little pigs are not real.
All they are is just underfed.
That's pretty fucking,
that's fucked up.
Like when those people have those little
tiny pig, she's like, that's not real.
They're just, oh it's a baby
pig. Gets a tiny little pig.
It's just going to stay tiny. No, if
you don't feed it, she'll stay tight.